with a lot of ancient cultures we focus
on the Kings the aristocratic you leave
what that makes up such a minor
percentage of the population I want to
know what I would have been drinking I
went into a pub 1,100 years ago my name
is Travis rub I make really old beer
[Music]
Travis isn't your everyday brew master
he and his team have put a spin on craft
beer by taking a look back in time to
brew ancient beers when we produce the
ancient Egyptian and ancient Peruvian
beer I made them as close as I possibly
could to exactly the way an ancient beer
would have been produced and they turned
out quite well in ancient times beer was
traditionally brewed in clay pots
there was no carbonation in your head a
very low alcohol content while Travis
Bruce's beer using modern equipment he
meticulously adjusts his recipes to
include ingredients used thousands of
years ago
turns out ancient beer is surprisingly
delicious
it is often presumed that the beer they
drink was very gross or unpalatable
because we want to presume they're just
dumb and don't know any better the
ancient Egyptian beer it's one of my
favorite beers to drink at the end of a
long day of work one of the biggest
challenges really in doing beer
archaeology is really defining these
recipes and brewing ancient beer on a
modern system is very very challenging
ancient beer has some unusual
ingredients such as baking yeast juniper
berries and mugwort it's constantly
thinking outside of the box how do I
bring in all of these elements and
ingredients but how do I still mimic the
steps in order to prepare for his next
brew Travis spends three to four months
researching ancient civilizations the
beer I'm working on right now is a
Viking leader was consumed probably at
least 1100 years ago according to the
archaeological record I think the beer
is a is a really phenomenal lens for
viewing history and viewing culture
throughout time because it really does
seem to unify people from this early as
8500 BCE to over the present the modern
consumer they can come experience what
it was that ancient people may have been
drinking and then realized that wow
they're not all that different than we
are and that's what's so fascinating to
me to watch that fluidity from one
culture to the next
[Music]
when you find a tree that has an apple
and just discovering new varieties it's
just I mean I live for that
I'm Annie Brennan my wife and I we
around our town and we forage for wild
apples and we make it into a series of
ciders based on where the apples are
located you sell at the Gramercy Tavern
yeah yeah Gramercy Tavern which I've
only not once
I know it's famous and especially their
wine menu is somewhat famous having
cider made from wild forged fruit is
really unusual something that can only
be done in very small amounts what comes
out of the bottle is really special
[Music]
we go out into the woods we go to places
where apples are not at all influenced
by human cultivation we're searching the
woods and sometimes it's difficult to
find the trees man if the light doesn't
hit the silver and the trunk just right
you may not even know it's an apple tree
you're in luck when you find not just
one or two but a whole forest of trees
which sometimes does exist what I love
is discovering varieties that are just
so peculiar you would never find them in
a grocery store the other day we found
an apple that has red flesh so you bite
into it and it just looks like a
pomegranate they're telling us process
takes about four hours to grind and
press enough juice to fill a barrel
think of those barrels as bears its
hibernating nine months after you
collected the apples that's when it's
ready
[Music]
we made tap handles for blood Weiser
Goose Island Miller Lite
you know I think this is a first with an
actual snow globe on a tap handle yeehaw
Pale Ale I like this one because it's
just a big awesome looking tap handle
Steagall Prescott and central waters to
name a few
a mark Steinhardt general manager of ajs
tap handles I definitely would try that
beer so a guy walks into a bar and the
first thing he does if it's me I look
what's on tap certainly the unique fat
handles pique your interest and might
push you to try that beer
I like this tap handle because I'm a
little biker we're located in random
lake Wisconsin which is about 45 minutes
north of Milwaukee
even though Wisconsin is a rural state
we produced tap handles for the mega
breweries on down to the smallest micro
group we believe we're the largest
domestic producer to tap atmosphere to
do this we ship out approximately a half
a million cap
we can produce the tap handle from start
to finish this is a very detailed tap
handle and I would guess takes about an
hour to hand paint all the detail on it
companies do try to have the most
eye-catching most unique tap handle in
bar than it is a cross between art and
manufacturing we always say our cap
handle will sell your first beer and
your beer will sell the rest
you
[Music]
come on this be about our streams which
make the school money untaught destiny
mother have been system and receipt card
Bahamas be emergency Koenig a Napoleon
assist a gifted average make pita my
name is dick Andrea
all defendants here in pyramids here in
the paradise Guttenberg and first are
competitive incentive whole cities
around our foreign friend Yvonne of
tidal power I and had apologized and
wound about the heavens no chef indeed
eloquent and P about Martin in the gear
petition Dubrow awry beaten Bianca's yet
stamp even Palin a society was McCallum
digital left of be a guru national
houses one since imposter designer
constant Meyer winner asana an anatomic
sister would fill out American tiny cell
find something out is retiring foreign
system a kindly nice solution understand
in the how to iron seeing current as I
saw in an hour Putin played a factor
Daniel averiguando vom delight MBA
pardon me mr. seta Zayn Malik assist
miss Watson's verified astanga portal
East Indies abolished in this equation
when you insert the opportunity currency
say the Peter Principle in here those s
in second years was thinking chicken and
fish pasta
[Music]
the Old Forge was named Britain's most
remote pub by the Guinness Book of World
Records it's located here in Noida
northern Scotland nearly everyone who
tries to get there dies in that blaze
okay this isn't Mordor
but it is tricky as we found out one
does not simply walk to the Old Forge
pub plan one we take the train isn't
that the train from Harry pulse' oh it
is so we pack our gear jump on the train
enjoy the breathtaking scenery arrive at
the Old Forge order a pint and no no it
doesn't work the train doesn't come - no
direct it hands in Malak terminal hey
wait who is this guy
my name is JP Robin and I'm the remotest
publican in mainland Britain oh okay
plan - we'll walk he's the plan we pack
our gear fill up our water bottles pack
some snacks hair for the Scottish
wilderness enjoy the breathtaking
scenery arrive at the Old Forge order a
plan and well you could but to be honest
I don't think you would because at the
18 miles hike and it's very buggy no
tracks just cross country through the
highlands and you could carry all your
gears all the way up I don't know it's
quite difficult it's two days hike one
night in the Buffy okay plan three we
drive we pack up our gear we hire a car
[Music]
make it a 4x4 and hit the road
enjoy the breathtaking scenery arrive at
the Old Forge order a pint and it's
totally impossible to drive here the
nearest road is 18 miles from here so
you need to park in Molly and jump on a
boat full time I would say around
hundred and thirty people or live on the
peninsula of course the tourism is the
main part of our business we're really
busy between the 1st of March and
mid-october we've got the backpackers
and hikers because we are one of the two
best hike in Scotland here here is
totally unspoiled no doubt is clearly
the last British wilderness ok final
plan we take the ferry we pack our game
buy a ticket get on the ferry enjoy the
breathtaking scene with my god there are
three whales right next to the boat
arrive Android art wave goodbye to the
ferry captain arrive at the Old Forge
order a pint M
[Music]
in the southern part of Croatia in the
peninsula of paljah Zak there is a
winemaker that does things a little
differently I mean by Odin a president
vino is promoter that's right this
winery ages their wine 75 feet beneath
the sea surface after growing up around
many traditional winemakers Edie had an
idea to combine his two favorite
pastimes scuba diving and drinking wine
so he decided to try an aged wine in the
sea well produced a movie No ooh
linen 140 Kotaku polygons a memorial to
avoid any leaks in these ancient storage
jars IDI uses a glass bottle to keep the
wine in and saltwater out he uses
custom-made cages that line the sea
floor to hold the wine in place both
estoy bonito warned ideal twist chapter
soon Adnan a primadonna respond oh dear
oh dear God in any cotton Adira
allo Bettina chassis previous occupant
nested on assess Dharana the say we
destroy a car Canasta
[Music]
temperatura McCoy Sweden as of the
javanese semolina eastern a virginal
star nurse' WT silly party Sheena
Jelena fact or ask me but Jenny Majnu
know to appear conclusion Avena and CED
it's the silence that differentiates his
unique underwater wine from the patent
sat response team Padma token Wadena
ceraadi bodhisattva to make a primitive
a dishonest or adivasis in astronomy
geometry it is Lukovic question Roger
Padma Shiva no Tetsu Hennessy organism
una Nana vino vino Dobby or gachi a pony
oak whose negative in on what's normal
or pakalana
me llamo was it a Tara's acrostic aqua
logical shoe bas Rutten business was
Papa's not his familiarity signature by
primary acrylic auras
[Music]